if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do
massive it dumps
big massive dumps
ducks dumps dumps
dumps
congratulations
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
big massive dumpster
[Music]
a massive
all right welcome everybody we actually
have really big breaking news i was
going to be streaming a little bit later
today we have a joe biden event at 5 15
where he's going to
try to get republicans to just do what
obviously is best for the country and
best for their states which is pass some
kind of infrastructure bill and do the
whole build back better thing that's in
45 minutes but we now have a situation
with a very explosive countdown timer um
where there is going to be a press
conference this story of you know the
whole missing white woman syndrome as
it's been kind of um
called by some
it's all coming to a head in that after
the disappearance and ultimately finding
the remains of gabby petito
her fiance or boyfriend brian laundry
went missing
where is he was he killed did he take
his own life what's going on the latest
is that um what are believed to be brian
laundry's belongings his brian laundry's
laundry for lack of a better term
um
were found near
human remains and moments from now
there's going to be a press conference
with the fbi where i am imagining
they're going to say something
and what that something is could be
we believe these are the remains of
brian laundry and if that's the case
does it appear as though he took his own
life or
we just don't know okay and i know some
people have been asking why i haven't
been talking about the story some people
are furious that i am covering this
today we're here you know that's what it
is we're just we're here right now and
we're standing by for this press
conference
happening very very soon so that's what
it is um the latest news i have a cnn
article here
a medical examiner and cadaver dog
called to park where investigators found
brian laundry's items or items
sarasota county medical examiner and
cadaver dog called today
items were found um statement at 4 30
they these were items of interest
elements of interest were within the
items of interest we would say
uh and we're going to hear about this i
mean we don't really need to speculate
too too much in that this is going to be
happening momentarily it is of
significant interest in general so we're
going to listen to that then we've got
joe biden in 45 minutes he's going to be
dropping the hammer on republicans and
saying a number of different things to
different people
potentially under a very high energy
paradigm that'll be at 5 15 p.m eastern
time so we'll do the brian laundry press
conference now i want to announce i have
a game to play with you guys as well um
i i sort of uh
came up with this idea on a whim and
then floated it by producer john and
producer john made it even better i had
the idea of let's see how out of touch i
am with um fast food
prices
because as you know i have not gone to
fast food restaurants in 20 years and
all these different things um and so i
said to john let's let's put something
together and then john even made it
better
by
setting the game up for me to guess not
only the price of different fast food
elements but also the number of calories
so like the first one we're not going to
play it right now but the first one
would be the the burger king hwapper
uh what is the price of such an item and
what is the number of calories so we'll
i've got five starbucks burger king etc
we're gonna play this a little later and
see how out of touch i am and you'll be
able to play along as well so that's
coming up a little bit later the first
one is going to be the burger king
whopper and we'll see how out of touch i
am and if i can just even though i
haven't visited any fast food
restaurants in decades
infer infer
some of the pricing and caloric
components
to these items that'll be after
the fbi press conference okay
um
and what else oh yesterday's
um
yesterday's viewer town hall went really
really well
so um we we're gonna start uploading
some of the top phone calls from
yesterday's town hall are starting to be
chopped up we're gonna be mincing them
we're going to be chopping them we're
going to be crushing and and uh
pulverizing and all these different
things with those of the yesterday's
stream and the clips will start to be
posted to the pacman live youtube
channel
um probably soon very soon okay so
that's that's happening as well and i
will again put together uh this offer
for folks
although we tend to do the viewer town
halls every couple months every few
months i will do one next week if we get
100 website members and twitch
subscribers today let's put some points
up on the board right now sort of like
the red sox hopefully we'll be doing
early momentarily i want to say thanks
to weather boxer who says your wife is
up in the air yeah that is where do i
have that one
i think it's here i don't even know what
i'm doing sir no hold on
sir he's better than i am oh where is it
sir your wife is up in the air there it
is weather boxer says your wife is up in
the air life is good has subscribed aunt
fufu
beef stews a new member via twitch flea
girl kind af
uh kicking us off with six already and
of course website memberships always
preferred at joinpackman.com
and the coupon code felony21 will save
you a felonious amount of money oh also
thanks to crash override and bajibo for
the twitch prime subscriptions
thanks to lime green skittles as well
let me also make a programming
announcement i am going to be
participating let me see if i can find
this
um
chess streamer anna kramling has very
generously invited me to participate
in a tournament some people call it a
tournament some people say tournament
there's a squid chess
game happening on sunday where there are
going to be a bunch of different squid
games related
chess
games
i don't even know what they the games
are i just said sure she we follow each
other and she's like do you want to play
in this thing i said sure and as you can
see i am the 28th participant david p
there's going to be 32 people total
um let's see who i've heard of here
i've heard of nico but i don't know who
that is haven't heard of these folks
i haven't heard of these folks
i know nemo nemo commented on one of my
chess matches previously uh i know levy
levy and i are in touch via twitter
regularly
who else here
anna rudolph
gm canty i'm familiar with
and that's it okay so i mean i'm almost
feeling like i'm way too old for this
thing but i'm gonna do it i think it'll
be good for content it'll be good for
community purposes and things like that
so that's gonna be sunday at 7 00 p.m
central
eastern no central european time
and uh that's 1 p.m here in the east
i don't even again i don't even
understand what the games are
but that's gonna be the thing all right
let's listen to this press conference
here good afternoon josh taylor with the
northport police department thank you
for your continued diligence on this
story and thanks for your patience
as you know the north port police
department has worked collaboratively
with the fbi throughout this
investigation
so special agent michael mcpherson is
going to make a prepared statement
there's not going to be any questions
today but hopefully it answers some of
them thank you
standing very strongly good afternoon my
name is michael mcpherson i'm the
special agent in charge of the fbi tampa
division
as you're aware the fbi and the
northport police department and our
state and local law enforcement partners
have been searching the area of the
carlton reserve
for brian laundry
a person of interest in the murder of
gabby pitido
earlier today
investigators found what appears to be
human remains
along with personal items such as a
backpack
and notebook belonging to brian laundry
these items were found in an area that
up until recently have been
underwater our evidence response team
is on scene using all available forensic
resources to process the area
it's likely the team will be on scene
for several days
i know you have a lot of questions but
we don't have all the answers yet
we are working diligently to get those
answers for you
we are grateful for the dedication and
professionalism of the north port police
department along with our partners from
the state and local agencies
complex investigations such as this
cannot be accomplished by what agency
alone
but there's just too many agencies to
name them all here today
portions of the mayakahachi creek
environment park
and carlton reserve
remain closed to the public until
further notice
this is an active and ongoing
investigation
so we asked the public to maintain
distance from any law enforcement
personnel equipment
vehicles and other related activity for
the safety of the public
and to protect the integrity of our work
we have no additional comment related to
today's activities
our fbi denver office is the lead
investigative agency and all future
inquiries should be directed to them
we appreciate the tremendous support
from the public
and continue to ask for your assistance
in bringing this investigation
to close
thank you
was the backpack found near the bottom
what an underwhelming presentation
okay so what did we learn
elements
believed to belong to brian laundry were
found
there were also human remains found that
they are not saying
whether they know
if the human remains
belong to brian laundry that is where we
are
at this point in time and we really
learned very very little from this press
conference so we're going to keep it
here as there's uh more potentially more
expected statements from what i'm
reading we're also going to be standing
by for joe biden
in about 39 minutes and that's going to
be on the white house uh let's see the
white house one as well we're gonna want
to make sure to have that
um here it is okay good so we've got
multiple streams ready to go and we're
gonna keep an eye right here uh a very
very brief statement
and um
partial remains yes as people are
pointing out partial remains is
interesting because it could mean any
number of different things that these
were partial remains and belongings
dropped there by some third party
or things could have been moved around
by animals we we just don't know it's
all completely speculative at this point
in time not much of a press conference
really a 45 second statement from a guy
who
quite frankly gave very little
information very very little information
um let's take a look at some super chats
here logan had a tough day at school
today many coveted deniers and
anti-vaxxers making his blood boil happy
to be watching your stream keep it up
thanks logan great to have you here
jimmy from philly says plaid plaid plaid
and more plaid i'm sure you're referring
to the tesla model s plaid right
uh that that must be
what jimmy is referring to
karen says you are hot david fire fire
fire googly eyes oh my goodness thank
you karen
pepe xanadu says fast food prices vary
by state which state are you going to
use i have no idea i don't know
and chakaseki says could you estimate
the amount of calories embodied is tr in
trump's famous white house fast food
photo which picture is that
let's see
trump white house fast food
right
yeah i don't know that's that's pretty
tough
um this is the trump white house fast
food photo
yeah
um that's that's you know the i can't do
math uh my calculator doesn't have
enough um digits for that yeah so i
don't know i don't know about that uh
let's say but there's more drama folks
here are showing pictures and uh sounds
like they are shouting at police let's
see if we can listen there's no audio on
this feature okay photographer from
channel 8 take the mic so there might
not be a mic at all and it might be
audio that again we don't know what kind
of language is being used here but um
you can see that they're they're cl
they're not shouting at police as much
as they are shouting at
photographers well it's cop now it's
very popular these days just to shout
people just shout if you look at these
school board meetings if you look at
even just like a regular trip to trader
joe's it's a lot of shouting shouting
shouting shouting endless shouting it's
very in right now to just scream at the
top of your lungs and
sometimes humiliate yourself
unfortunately there's a lot of it a lot
of it a lot of it
um
okay so we're standing by for joe biden
and potentially more here on this brian
laundry situation
um let me go to a couple of other things
i wanted to do oh thanks to napa skip
dog
chronic masticator and lime green
skittles for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 12.
we do have on the table
another
hour plus 75-ish 80-minute live viewer
town hall
early next week basically five days from
now
if we get to 100 website members and
twitch subscribers today we will
schedule i'll do it right now i'll pull
up the schedule and do it right now
another live viewer town hall
so uh today is a great day to sign up on
my website and in fact i want to say
thanks to mar morgan mar morgan just
signed up at
joinpakman.com
not using a coupon code mind you the
coupon code is available it's not
mandatory
not mandatory important thing to mention
okay
let's go next to
uh
let's see
oh this is pretty good someone made a
deep fake of me as the famous
argentinian soccer player
diego maradona this is really really
good
um me being argentinian of course it's
really hitting all the right notes let's
take a quick look at it
look at that
very very that those were crazy days
those were really crazy days when i did
the hand of god and everything it was it
was wild
um okay so we've got that
you guys want to see a toe curling video
um
so i i don't even fully understand this
story because it's
so
bizarre
uh you guys know q anon of course
so
there is a an assertion
that the mastermind of q anon is this
guy named joe watkins
just the picture already scares children
um
i guess that he's now running for let me
see what is he running for
he's running in arizona
and
he did a vid let's actually pull up the
video this is quite this really is a toe
curling video he announced his run
where is where's the clip
ah here it is he announced he's running
for something again
and it is so creepy
so creepy um you can tell that he's
reading a script
and the delivery suggests absolutely no
ability to sense uh feel emotion
whatsoever it's it's just a disgusting
video and supposedly some people believe
this is the q and on mastermind let's
take a look at this
this is ron watkins
here again outside a.g brnovich's office
i want to congratulate our ag for
proceeding on election fraud cases what
why is this so creepy seriously why is
the what about it is it that this is so
creepy
i also want to emphasize that we must
stay vigilant and keep up the pressure
both here in arizona and throughout the
country
to indict any and all criminals who have
facilitated election fraud
president trump had his election stolen
not just in arizona but in other states
too
we must now take this fight to
washington dc
and vote out all the dirty democrats who
have stolen our republic
we must fix selections from inside them
like imagine if if the entire queue
thing is really just this guy it's sort
of underwhelming it's like uh
is it correct me if i'm wrong would it
be sort of like wizard of oz
where at the end you find out i don't
even remember like you know the whole
thing it's like there's this little
is that is that maybe an analogy
yeah and then it's like this is the this
q anon all came from this guy that's
what you're telling me
i've decided to expose the dirtiest
democrat in the dc swamp oh and some of
you here may already know him as
congressman tom o'halloran
representing maricopa county and
district one right
what's publicly known about tommo
hooligan
really charismatic guy huh i mean just
inspires and inspires really a leader
born leader that he is not fit to
represent the people of arizona
and from what i've already discovered
and will expose
tom is not fit to represent anyone
anywhere
after attending a recent sermon by
pastor jeff durbin of apologia church
i've come to realize that following
god's word is not always the easiest
route
but if we don't follow our beliefs and
the founding principles of our nation
it will crumble
this must stop now
therefore i've decided to double down
with god as my compass whoa
now it's getting very serious to take
this fight to the swamp of washington dc
i am here to formally announce my run
for congress
in arizona district number one
our fight has only just begun and i
can't do it alone
i will need your support
together we will beat tom hooligan
and under god's authority we will take
back congress flip the senate and fix
the presidency
thank you
now as as toe-curlingly cringe-worthy as
that is
i i think any of these people could win
i mean the you know voters in arizona
arizona's been moving in the right
direction but you look at some of these
districts it's not obvious to me that he
can't win i mean it's hard to imagine a
less charismatic candidate
for anything
um
it's hard to imagine anybody i would
more be eager to keep away from children
but
anybody could win i mean look trump won
so what do you know who the hell knows
it's all it's all really really crazy
um
so that's that we'll take care of that
and we did this
oh speaking of cringe
this is joni ernst today
i guess talking about delayed deliveries
on the floor of the house and it's just
as depressing that she's a senator i
mean look at this staffed and folks this
crisis isn't ending
anytime soon
the upcoming holiday season is already
being referred to as biden's blue
christmas
hmm the white house is even worse now
hold on a second
is it pete budege's fault that there's
delayed packages because he's on
paternity leave or is it joe biden's
fault
i'm confused now
there will be items people can't get for
chris christmas so let's just hope for
the sake of the kids who have been good
all year
that biden's broken supply chain
problems don't extend all the way to the
north pole wow what a powerful
indictment
really just pointing out all of the ways
in which the biden administration has
has gone wrong what what a bizarre what
a bizarre person
uh okay we're keeping an eye and waiting
for joe biden he'll be
speaking in a little bit um and also
keeping an eye as to whether there will
be more news about the potential
about brian laundry's items that were
found as well as the partial human
remains that were found there as well
let's look at a few super chats
renholder says you need to watch cue
into the storm on hbo for more info on
ron watkins and his father interesting
christian says actually surprised this
wasn't a segment on missing white woman
syndrome right
larry says hello david hope you've been
well was wondering if you've seen ben
glibe's debate with charlie kirk or his
video from the anti-vaxx restaurant in
l.a no let's look up the anti-vaxx
restaurant in l.a i saw a little bit of
the debate with charlie kirk uh ben
glibe
restaurant let's check that out
full video comedian d masked and thrown
out of anti-vasque vax restaurant oh
let's check this out yeah there's an
anti-vaxx restaurant in la
check this out
by the way how do you prove you're not
vaccinated
how's business tonight
busy huh
has it been like next level busy since
you guys took your stand so we had
four to five hour lines like until
everything reopened up and then since we
got back on the news and everything down
having an hour to our way stuff like
that just like wow
waiting two hours to eat without a mask
with unvaccinated people
why it's nice to have a place that kind
of puts their foot down for freedom and
says
we don't care about this deadly virus
we're gonna
put our foot down and and just do it our
way
isn't that cool
i love it i love it it's all about
freedom right absolutely it is yeah
have you guys had any backlash from
people coming in
oh you're talking about like the people
that don't support us coming here no
they just call over the phone they never
really show up hours yeah exactly
all we really get coming to the
restaurant is supporters and we get the
cowards on the phone how are you guys
enforcing the none
how do you make sure you say you have to
prove you're not vaccinated just take
your report on it all right
it's like you know
it's time to figure it out for yourself
yeah yeah
oh man it's like he doesn't totally seem
to even understand the question which is
like how do you prove a negative
listen listen i'm not vaccinated look i
don't have any vaccine card
well could the vaccine maybe the vaccine
card maybe be at home no no no
that's proof i'm not vaccinated
have you heard about the new delta
variant though
this one i'm starting to actually come
around and believe it's very contagious
we need to maybe wear masks and get
vaccinated and stuff
yeah the vaccination is tough
you think it's college yes
and you have a science background right
now
what are you doing
um
see you later i do all sorts of things
in the medical field i miss everything
from
she's involved in different elements of
medical it's cool
that's the same as like cdc work really
it's like it's equal
ability to you know kind of
one side knows that this guy's really
good feeling about it
both need to be respected yeah
a lot of people are like oh my family
members it's like
you got others don't worry about it
100 of the elderly people that i know
would have rather
died six months earlier of cobin because
their family came and saw them than
dying alone for six months in a room not
being taken care of right all these old
folks that are now alive are sitting
around saying
i wish i had been dead for six months
tons of people you
just everywhere everybody's saying i'm
mad i survived
that's it that's a that's a big argument
that you don't hear a lot that you don't
hear a lot but it's true it's like
some people would rather die so why
deprive them of that right you know
i love it how they say the science right
i'm going to choose geology if i'm going
to choose a science because yeah
yeah what do you mean if science was one
thing why would there be so many fields
within it
the greatest fallacy is the science is
settled that isn't how science works
right you're always questioning your
hypothesis right science evolves yes but
in order to change it you need something
compelling and factual to make us change
what the accepted current understanding
is they don't care you have to adjust
based on the facts and
they got everybody so frightened yeah
right
by the way it doesn't even really look
that busy
that they might die
of
something the deadly virus or whatever
that's killing me
[Music]
poor kid we've never had a problem
[Music]
have you guys heard about these people
that are getting vaccinated and not
telling their friends that they got
vaccinated because they're embarrassed
oh i'm sure
i don't know any personally but i'm sure
i'm one of them
i got vaccinated and i don't want
anybody to know because i'm embarrassed
because all my a lot of my friends and
and they're they're right but they're
anti-science and not buying into the
facts and i'm like i got the vaccine i
don't want to talk about it
do you look down upon me because i got
the vaccine
no are you an [ __ ]
oh
[Music]
i only did it because i'm trying to not
die from the from the from the virus
thank you so much man
thank you very much
get out of here what do you mean got
i just want to make sure that i'm
getting exposed to anything hey get out
of here guys you guys are all gone you
don't even have to pay get out of here
take these off
but you can't pull the mask off get out
of here
take my mask off my face is that is that
assault of some kind get out of here go
we told you to leave
yeah
who cares i don't care
turn around and start walking i'm sorry
i'm sorry like is that any different
than pulling a watch off of someone
legally speaking anybody
i'll never do that again never come back
here again i'll never do it again i
don't want it i just wanted to protect
everybody i wanted to i just wanted to
be there
that's fine that's fine look my bad i
just wanted to help out and not breathe
on everybody but like teach their own
horse
you want to breathe in people with cold
stuff that's fine
right there what is you're a nazi friend
because i don't want to infect people
you can never tell with these people
whether being a nazi brown shirt is good
or bad
turn around and leave
don't talk to our customers
they're for free speech but they're
saying you're not allowed to speak to
our customers i'm sure people have a
good chance to get sick i get that i get
it
that's what america's about infecting
fellow citizens because you don't want
to wear a piece of cloth i get that
i get it it makes sense to me
not follow the science but just follow
being a baby about a mask nobody cares
about what you're saying man get out of
here
you're very riled up
i'm just saying yeah they're all for
letting people do whatever they want
unless what they want to do
is get vaccinated mention it wear a mask
or whatever man that's really good
that's really really good i like that
that's uh that's actually that's
excellent very nice work
um i want to say thanks to greenman now
subscribed on twitch for 20 months in a
row also thanks to vatarette
jen here
lemony's
noodle mixing sound
geoventure
and k shreds that's one two three four
five six
seven
thirteen plus seven seven plus three is
ten zero carry the one one plus one is
two that puts us at twenty
puts us at twenty
and over on the website also want to say
thanks to
mary alexander who has just signed up at
joinpackman.com number 21.
folks today is a great day to grab a
membership on our website the number one
way to support the work that we do join
pacman.com this coupon code felony21
don't tell your attorney general
uh it is it is criminally
huge the discount criminally huge bigger
than trump's ego
but uh it's best not to speak it out
loud just type it in and not worry too
much about it
okay other super chats here coming in
um
the fight on christmas begins early with
poster board underwhelmed right
it's pronounced glebe okay ben glebe ben
glebe i apologize
david sir price of goods and gas risen a
bit in rural michigan everyone i've
spoken with blames biden more trump
flags popping up than before the
election what are your thoughts it's
actually uh it's happening it's
happening nationally you know supply
chain issues under trump
now under biden now it's biden's fault
it wasn't trump's fault now it's pete
budeh judge's fault it wasn't elaine
chow's fault they're hypocrites
gas prices are up they were up at one
point under trump then it wasn't trump's
fault
now it's biden's fault it's you know the
it's it's it is what it is
um
have you seen jordan klepper's latest
video talking to trump supporters at the
iowa rally yeah let's do that a little
bit later um jordan clepper iowa rally
we'll pull that up in a bit uh i've got
a few other things to go through first
so we'll get back to that from the
standpoint of crimes pulling a mask off
someone sounds like assault it does to
me too elon musk signed up for the squid
chess tournament great so i'll be
playing again yeah if you miss that i'm
going to be playing in a squid chess
tournament organized by
chess streamer anna kramling on um
sunday at 1 pm eastern time
and
i don't even know what the games are she
said the games will be revealed on the
day of
so hopefully they're not too complicated
but that'll be the the rare weekend
stream
as we stand by here
for joe biden
um okay
very good
let's get over to
should i do voicemails now or do a
couple of other things
a couple of other things going let's
let's go to this video next um
this has been an ongoing thing
congressman jim jordan
we just can't seem to get him to answer
how many times he spoke to trump on the
day of the trump riots
we are inferring that the reason he
doesn't want to clearly answer that
question
is because it would
lead to more questions about what he
knew and when and his motivations and
trump's motivations etc
um
so
at one point he said i spoke to trump i
think on that day and
it might have been before the riot but
it might have been after we then got him
to admit that he was we i mean another
reporter got him to admit that it was
actually twice so here congressman jim
mcgovern
who i i bumped into not long ago at a
cafe actually when i was out in western
massachusetts
he is asking exactly how many times he
spoke to trump on january 6th and like
you just can't get an answer from jim
jordan you were asked by brett bear on
fox news
if you talk to the former president on
january 6th
and you you didn't give a clear answer
you said and i quote i've talked to the
president so many i can't remember all
the days i've talked to him but i've
certainly talked to the president end
quote the next day on july 28 you
confirmed to spectrum news that you
spoke with the former president on
january 6th
when asked by a spectrum news reporter
taylor popolars
whether you spoke to the president
before during or after the capital was
attacked you said and i quote
i spoke with him that day after i think
after i don't know if i spoke with him
the more in the morning
i just don't know i have to give back to
you i don't it was crazy i don't know
when i spoke to him nor do i have any
way of looking at phone records i don't
know when those conversations happen end
quote yep so my question is you've had
84 days since that interview to go back
and check the record so when did you
speak with the former president on
january 6 did you talk to the former
president before man jim jordan will not
stop trying to interrupt or after the
attack on the capitol of course i've
talked to the president of course i've
talked to the president i've been clear
about that i talked to him all the time
um
this is not about me mr chairman you see
how he's still not answering he's still
not answering the question i know you
want to make it about me you want to
make it about
uh
individuals uh other individuals
but this is about the lack of a proper
security presence that day that's what
this committee if this company's gonna
do something that's worthwhile that's
what they should be investigating of
course i talked to the president i
talked to him that day i've been clear
about that yeah we that you've not been
clear in terms of how many times and
when
i don't recall the number of times but
it's not about me i know you want to
make it about that but this is about why
was it how about this why wasn't the
national guard here that day mr chairman
well part of that is because of trump
actually so you see how dishonest this
guy is it's truly just disgusting he
just will not answer he will not answer
that question he's at 84 days i'm sure
he knows the answer at this point it's
like how could he possibly not know the
answer he's been asked so many times
uh but just just a vile and disgusting
guy thanks to real time fan as well as
crowbars forever for the twitch prime
subscriptions numbers 22 and 23 today
if and when we get to 100 total across
twitch and our website we'll schedule
another live viewer town hall for next
week and just take calls massive dumps
of call call after call after call let's
listen in a little bit here to wfla's
coverage to see if it looks like there
will be more updates about the brian
laundry stuff we are still standing by
for joe biden scheduled to speak in
under 15 minutes so that's coming up as
well a lot happening today he's no
longer with us can't so that's another
question can he go from person of
interest to suspect if he's dead
even if they find more evidence what
would be the use of that other than
i don't know i don't know what would be
the use of that
a lot of questions
news conference was a surprise i'll be
honest i'll be honest i was surprised
that they
the notebook now is going to be the
subject
of
threads online
comments
the amount of attention that this
notebook is going to receive this is
going to be the most famous notebook in
the world or the most infamous notebook
in the world everyone's going to want to
that i don't know about that may be a
little bit histrionic uh and we had a
commenter here
the honest part i was surprised that
they even gave us that i i would have it
would have no one would have blinked an
eye if they had just said we found a
backpack really good point very good we
just found a backpack and then we found
remains and that was that was that was
the contents of the press conference
itself was just those two
those two two announcements but the
notebook is an add-on now that is i
already see it it's happening in real
time interactively here i'm watching it
happen on all these platforms people are
now asking
what is in the notebook it's gonna be a
hashtag in no time presumably writing
would be my guess
um okay so we're gonna keep it here and
and see uh what uh else crops up as far
as that goes okay do you guys wanna do
the fast food uh me david pakman fast
food out of touch game or do you want to
listen to some voicemails we'll do both
as we wait for joe biden but is there a
preference as to which we do first i
guess is what i'm saying
to you fine folks
fast food game or voicemails
seems mostly everybody wants the fast
food game all right
or my confession yeah either way we
could we could go either way thanks to e
king for subscribing via twitch prime i
appreciate that number 24 today thank
you very much also a huge thank you
to jordy bel-air for signing up on my
website with the coupon code felony21
jordy i'm gonna do you a favor
i'm not gonna even mention how deep that
discount is with the code felony 21. i
don't want to get you in trouble
but i do appreciate you signing up jordy
bel-air at
joinpacman.com is new member number 25
today
you can join jordy yourself yeah big big
trouble
big trouble all right let's do the fast
food game okay as we stand by for joe
biden here's the way this game is going
to work i am going to be presented with
five different fast food elements
and i am going to have to guess what is
the cost of such an item now some people
said in what state i don't know i i
couldn't be involved in the planning of
this because then i would know the
answers right so i have no i think maybe
it's an average or whatever
i don't know if there's an index price
so
what does the price of this item stand
alone the sale price the sale price not
the cost to produce the sale price of
the item
and what is the number of calories
calories okay
so the first is the burger king whopper
i'm gonna let's do calories first
my guesses were probably talking about
let me let me let's think it through
basically okay as described here
the majority of the calories now is
there cheese on a whopper by default is
there cheese on a whopper by default
does anybody know that i'm not seeing
cheese
here in this picture
i it doesn't look like there is there's
no cheese by default we're going to
assume it's no cheese okay
my guess is
the bun is about 120 calories
there's probably
some butter slash oil may be good for
another
a lot of times the oil is a lot of the
calories let's put let's say 80. let's
say between the bun and the oil we're at
200 calories
um
whatever mayo like sauce sauces on there
you're probably talking another 70 80
calories there so now we're at like 280
the patty
meat is is surprisingly low in calories
but let's say it's another hundred so
we're at like 380
and then miscellaneous other things and
then just like i should probably add
more because i'm probably
underestimating
let's assume i'm gonna say that this
sandwich is
550 calories 550 calories
and that it costs
i'm going to say 4.99
4.99
550 calories let's take a look
419
660. okay so i came in
high i came in 80 cents high on price
and i came in 110 calories low i'm not
totally out of touch though
i'm not totally out of touch i mean i'm
in the ballpark given i haven't been to
a fast food restaurant in 20 years
not bad
not bad
all right let's go to the next one
this is chick-fil-a medium waffle fries
medium waffle fries oof okay so
basically you've got you've got really
three elements here right you've got
potato
oil
and salt salt has almost no calories
right
um
medium waffle fry now one of the things
i know
is that in these fast food meals
the calories from potatoes are cheap so
oftentimes those are bolstered if you
want to you know you you get these 900
calorie fast food meals
the potatoes are cheap calories so not
only the potatoes but the oil are a big
part of that
i'm gonna guess that a medium waffle fry
medium waffle fry let me think about
that
could it be three bucks
maybe three bucks let's say 299 on the
price
and let's say
200 and
i almost want to say that this is 300
cents and 300 calories let's take a look
oh my god
165
way high on price
and i was also low on calories so i was
120 calories under
but i was a dollar 35 over on price
that's interesting
huh
well it
there's a reason that potatoes are a
profit uh center for fast food potatoes
are cheap calories cheap calories
all right let's go next oh boy regular
size mcdonald's oreo mcflurry oh hold on
let me just make sure we're not missing
joe biden
uh
okay no we're good we're good for now
okay
let's continue
mcdonald's oreo mcflurry
ugh this has got to be
it's got to be a lot of is i guess the
first question is is this more or fewer
calories
than the whopper
it's a lot of heavy cream and sugar
the whopper was 660.
i'm going to say it's less i'm going to
say this is 500 calories
and i'm going to say it's
and fifty cents
oh okay not bad not bad so it's 239 i i
i guessed uh four dollars and fifty
cents
500 calories so i was over on price this
is actually far cheaper and a little bit
over on calories but i'm i'm very much
in the ballpark there very much in the
ballpark all right i but yeah i don't
need any of this stuff i know people are
saying i shouldn't i don't eat any of
this i haven't been to a fast food in a
long time okay here we now we're now
we're getting into something interesting
people talk about getting coffee oh but
it's so many calories it's unhealthy
coffee is very low in calories espresso
is like no calories it's basically water
okay
uh what is a shot of espresso is it like
15 calories or something like that
calories in shot of espresso
three
apparently there's three calories in a
shot of espresso okay
calories in
six or let's and it's actually four
ounces of milk
at one percent no but we need let's
imagine that it's whole milk whole milk
four ounces 68 calories wow so like a
cappuccino
is not a lot of calories so but the
truth is these are not really coffee
drinks these have some coffee
but they have sugars
they have whipped cream sometimes they
have syrups they have all of these
different things and it is crazy it's a
dessert based on coffee exactly so for
something like this
is the grande big or is that medium does
anybody know
guys i'm not looking up the calories in
this i'm just telling people when we
talk about coffee this is not what we're
talking about
grande is a medium
pumpkin spice latte
i wouldn't be surprised if this was 500
calories
let's say 500 calories and six dollars
500 calories and six dollars
no okay all right a little bit over so
that's 495 and 390 calories
yeah that's that's pretty nuts
that's pretty nuts
i would not order that don't get any of
this stuff
all right and then let's go to the last
one a taco bell
cheesy gordita crunch
my instinct is that this is pretty cheap
because i remember taco bell being cheap
how much could this cost one taco bell
cheesy gordita crunch
could this be three dollars
could this be a three dollar item
maybe
let's go with three dollars and for
calories
i'm going to say um
[Music]
3.75
3.375
399 500 calories okay again i'm in the
ballpark i'm in the ballpark i'm not
totally out of touch so that's the game
guys that's the fast food game i
appreciate everybody playing along with
me i think it was very very well put
together uh by producer john
um maybe we'll do it uh maybe we'll do
it again at some point in the future but
a very very good game and
even though i've been out of the fast
food game for 20 years
you know it's not like i'm bill gates
where i'm like you know
could a banana really be that much more
than ten dollars i'm not in that
position
i'm not in that position all right let
me say thank you to a few other people
texas bear claw has just subscribed via
twitch also kismar has gifted five subs
that's a total of six
putting us at 31 for the day 31
and if we get to 100 we will schedule
another live viewer town hall for some
time during the next week
and do i have anyone to thank over on
the website
no it's slow going over on the website
today let's do this extra incentive all
right
for today only
website memberships count double
they count double in our quest to get to
a hundred and the code works
and the code works
which is
my oh i think that's my lawyer at the
door and accountant saying don't do it
we're doing it though we're doing it
all right as we stand by here for joe
biden and continue to keep an eye on the
brian laundry situation
uh larry says thanks so much for
watching and showing the video and
promoting a great comedian you have to
watch the entire charlie kirk debate
it's amazing yeah i will check it out
i've seen a few clips biden said no
president should hold office after
seeing 200 000 deaths from covid i'm
very worried this will be a talking
point in the future what are your
thoughts
it may be
it may be
trump has the republican nomination in
the bag if he wants to run again in 24
i'm terrified about the prospect of
another four years of him how will we
cope let's take it a step at a time
let's see what happens in the midterms
first
and then we can look at 2024
also let's not assume that his health is
going to be great in 2024
um
it remains to be seen there's a lot of
questions a lot a lot of questions here
okay standing by for joe biden oh okay
joe biden's about to speak so we're
gonna stand by for that let's listen to
a couple of voicemails
while we wait
um
as we stand by for joe biden just to get
through a couple of these all of the
usual suspects are calling in feverantly
so um chris christie is going to like
bring people out um must
like open up the economy and stuff like
that but take like preventative measures
so it would be like hasn't chris
christie not been governor for like
years
uh next caller
and well we're talking about colorado
and they the spirits will call i don't
want to say god okay because everybody
has god as a single entity so right
hi uh so i found something else
that um
[Music]
looked like
um
kind of like a suspicious sign that
government was involved or like
specifically more trump
was involved in the 9 11 attacks
okay
so let's go through some facts here i
was electrocuted june 3rd 2002 at age 26
for about 90 seconds to a minute and a
half about 12 feet up on a roof patch
pretty much in the position of the
crucifixion on the cross
exactly yeah hey david it's eric again
i'm willing to uh share all this
information with you like i said it's in
the stats and the data um
uh hospitals were getting paid to put
covert down as the cause of death nope
already debunked sorry
so i was doing like more background
research on shapiro because like um i
was trying to understand like where he
was meeting by this one comment that he
made
very important research
all right i guess we're having a little
negotiation here over the phone david
i'm sorry to involve you in this [ __ ]
but
so far i see trump trump's an alien he
thinks that he wants to stay here and
i'm telling he can't
right he's got to go back to his home
planet very well said
so people need to explain like having a
baby
as
like if you have a baby with somebody
in
[Music]
like
okay
so
you guys need to learn cpr right we're
going to learn it very soon all right
now we've got some maybe quote normal
voicemails to listen to
hi david i'm calling from missouri and i
just want to let you know that i love
the way you explain things
you explain it to where i can understand
it because i know politics gets so
i don't even know the word to describe
it but anyway i really enjoy watching
your show
thank you subscribe to you that's a nice
voicemail i like it
horseshit
i routinely watch you on youtube
the last time i dialed up one of your
videos
i was offered two mandatory ads
i killed that video
i won't watch it
when you mandate that i watch your
advertisements
okay
thank you very much for letting me know
hi david um i was watching your show a
couple days ago and i saw um you went
over the
kind of conspiracy theory that
uh cormenati in europe is actually the
approved coven vaccine and that the
pfizer vaccine being distributed in in
the us did not receive
approval
um i overheard my coworker discussing
this and
someone else corrected him and
said essentially what
he spelled on on the show that the
cormonady vaccine is chemically
identical to the
fiber vaccine in the u.s right and then
he said something like
that the fda normally when there's drugs
that serve the same purpose
um
for um treating the same disease and
some are on emergencies yeah well now we
get into some more kind of uh
you know into the weeds but yes that i'm
glad i'm very very glad
that that's what that was cleared up
so i'm having like a lot of problems
over here
um
it seems
like
they're like
doing weird stuff
like
the lawyers are
not really explaining things to people
the lawyers must explain yes
mr david pakman
i just seen a little
a bit of uh
the alex jones nut
uh doing a little bit on ivermectin
and
you know
i think he's a i think he's a cracky
crazy guy
but he didn't
the pill was in the other hand not the
water hand i know no i know he only
pretended to take the ivermectin that's
that's true we did cover that and that's
absolutely accurate i want to say thank
you to laura tisinsick who just signed
up on my website and as promised
as promised
website memberships count double today
so instead of just putting us at 32
that puts us at 33.
that is really something folks let's
listen to a few more of these voicemails
as we stand by here for joe biden
hey david it's eric from mass uh you
should check out the new documentary
covet land right um
all i can say is uh are you gonna
believe what you're told or you're gonna
believe
you're lying eyes i mean
this lays it out perfectly
this is exactly what i was trying to
tell you
checkmate
checkmate that is the yes
exactly all right couple more
i found some near family online from
ukraine who's also jewish moved here to
america when he was five
and
we could totally be like family for sure
now
i might be related to whitney go figure
that's interesting
hey david it's everett from mass um
man you're in a free fall nose dive of
course that's continuing to go on
let's see what else we've got here
hey david in 2024 if we kind of
uh don't look at who wins on the
democratic side
if the republicans run trump again and
he loses
do you see what do you see happening are
the
are conservatives going to kind of
go with trump light with a ron desantis
or are they going to totally swing back
and look more for
like a mitt romney or john mccain i
think i think it's too early to say i
think if republicans get crushed in 22
they'll more proactively go for
something different than trump i think
if they do well in 22
it's totally plausible that trump gets
right in there i think it's completely
plausible
hey david it's your kansas claw hopper
again
you know the rest of the tale
anyway
i've heard a couple of new things
recently one of them where you know
crony capitalism has turned into
surveillance capitalism
and the root of so many of these things
comes down to something called
cognitive dissonance
it's
to me
just the basis of
what results from an uneducated
population that can go around with
whatever
and you know
the i am not understanding the
connection that's being made there i it
may be my fault
hi david my name's darren i'm from
california i've called a few times now
um
i just wanted to ask because i'm i'm
watching your segment about tucker going
full conspiracy in an outrageous rant
about this
fake
office room from the white house that
they built across the street in a studio
setting
part of me
and a lot of the right seems to talk
about
um
how bad it is that joe biden has to use
a teleprompter oh my goodness he's using
a teleprompter when at the same time
uh they are using a teleprompter a lot
of their associates and co-workers
they deliver those segments off of a
teleprompter
not to mention that i don't think it's
really a bad thing
that someone like the president uses a
teleprompter when they're trying to
get through to the public with a lot of
information on a daily basis why do you
think this teleprompter talk besides
joe biden being senile
yeah no they said it about obama also
and what's funny is trump would
regularly use a teleprompter and even
when he didn't he would just have his
speech printed out like is it if you're
is it really different if it's on paper
than if you're reading it off of it's
the same speech you're still reading
your speech
it's uh it's a strange criticism for
sure
hello david my name is tim i live in now
washington and i just watched your
youtube presentation about the truth
about the debt ceiling
and i enjoyed your conversation uh but
it struck me that you know we we seem to
always
worry about um
how much we're spending her and we
don't talk
that talk about that in conjunction with
how much we have decided
to cut our income
through tax cuts i know we talk a lot
about
what the right wants to do with cutting
taxes and that we've cut corporate taxes
and
and we've reduced our income by a lot so
balancing the budget is is really
critical
when it comes to
balancing income against what we spend
yeah this but this entire paradigm is
sort of antiquated in the sense that
just balancing the budget is not
virtuous in and of itself and um a
national economy
is not the same as like a household
economy
um and we we've got to be thinking about
these things just a little bit
differently a little bit differently
well that doesn't work
whoa what was that that's weird
all right couple more
hello david pakman i am hunter williams
calling in
from minnesota
that cases are down in
most of the states that's upper five i
was just wondering when do you think
we will get back to normal
if
we can keep the back if we can keep the
vaccines at a high rate and if we can
keep the cases down at a
low marginal number
it depends what you mean by normal
hunter um there's every indication that
covets going to be endemic and i don't
even know what normal means at this
point we do have to vaccinate more
people we have to see cases get lower
hopefully as vincent racanello said is
most likely the virus will also weaken
over time
it's going to be a new normal
it's going to be a new normal is i think
the way that i would say it
what is it about ivanka that like seems
so scary because i'm like watching the
news or why watch the news like the
entire time the trump administration was
and like people were saying like she's
like a princess and like all this kind
of stuff yep no that's all really crazy
stuff
yeah david this is alan calling from
texas
and my question is
why
are
the republicans
and conservatives
all so gullible
that they are falling for nothing but
lies
have they been conditioned to fall for
lies all these years or
i'm just trying to figure this out there
has to be a logical explanation
why so many people are following and
that's a complicated text so to speak
um
hey welcome to uh everybody coming over
from watching jeff waldorf welcome
everybody great to have you here over on
twitch we're just standing by here for
joe biden um that's a very complicated
topic on which i have a number of clips
but there are some important differences
with republicans that explain there are
cultural differences and other
differences that explain why they fall
uh for a lot of this crap um people
asking whether i'm going to be getting
my moderna booster
we actually talked about this on the
bonus show today i don't know
i don't know the uh let's look at there
was just news let's see if joe biden's
speaking we'll look at it after let's
see what's going on
i guess we're still standing by for joe
so let's see
the fda authorizes moderna and j and j
coveted boosters okay
um
unanimous vote
fda also authorized boosters that differ
from your original vaccine type that's
fine
opens the gate for boosters to be used
more widely
available data suggest waning immunity
in some populations who are fully
vaccinated
uh mix and match approach
mixed vaccine combination
people can get whichever shot
moderna
whoa
alright stand by
please welcome the president of the
united states joe
biden these aren't people these are
animals
cauli
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is shane cauley
and i'm a fourth generation
union iron worker
i was born and raised right here in
scranton
not green ridge but west side
i'm a proud member of iron workers local
404 and i've worked on many projects all
over the northeast during my 15 years in
the trade
i'm a married man and the proud father
of two daughters ages 14
and two
and a four-year-old son i'm invested in
my community and i serve as a township
auditor in ransom township and i'm a
proud member of the st patrick's parade
day association of lackawanna county
president biden's build buildback better
agenda is important for working families
just like mine
in pennsylvania and across the country
we work hard for every dollar that we
earn but some days it feels like the
odds are stacked against us
the historic infrastructure investments
in the bipartisan infrastructure deal
would put food on my family's table for
years to come
but president biden's broader vision
would go further
the build back better act addresses the
rising cost of both child care
and elder care which would help ensure
that both my young son
my daughters and my aging parents
are taken care of with dignity grace and
understanding
my wife is going to school for nursing
but with three kids
and both of us working
it's tough to find enough hours in the
day
joe biden's american rescue plan gave us
an expanded child tax credit which helps
us to cover the cost of two weeks of
child care every single month
this has given my wife the flexibility
to devote more time to her studies
president biden's build back better act
would extend the child tax credit and
invest more in child care helping my
family and families just like mine
with this help my wife and others like
her
will be able to pursue their passion for
helping others and fill a role in health
care that our community desperately
needs right now
my wife and i have talked about the
possibility of having more children one
day
but
like millions of americans
i only get paid for the days i lace my
boots up and go to work right i have
zero paid time off
for the birth of a new child but the
paid family leave called for and the
build back better act would give my wife
and i the ability to plan for another
child with less worrying about making
ends meet
we will be able to focus on what truly
matters
our family
and without further ado it's my honor
and my privilege to introduce to all of
you the president of the united states
of america
joe
hello hello hello
it's good to be home
thank you all please please be seated
i just want you to know we have a
tradition in the
biden finnegan family
when you see a relative you go see them
first these are my relatives in the
front row here i want you to know
[Applause]
and uh
spent an awful lot of time uh
across from saint paul's uh church at my
uncle jack finnegan's house
his daughters are here
and uh
he was uh he taught up at the u
and uh
i i just want you to know that
amtrak is here they can tell you that
you could you should name half the line
after me
i am the most railroad guy you're ever
going to meet
2 million 100 000 miles on amtrak
hear me now
not a joke
what happened was
when you are
a president or vice president they keep
meticulous mileage of when you fly an
air force aircraft
and so about uh i guess it was uh seven
years in
to uh to my tenure as vice president
and i used to always like to uh
take amtrak home on friday my i tried to
go home and see my mom who was
living with us at the time after my dad
passed and i try to get home
and uh the secret service are wonderful
they're the best in the world they never
liked me taking amtrak because it stops
too often and too many people can get on
and you don't know
and uh but i also there was uh but i uh
it turned out i was about number
three in seniority on the road at the
time if you're
not in terms of actual time on the road
and uh a lot of the folks in amtrak
became my family not a joke
i'd ride every day i i commuted every
single day for 36 years as
president vice president united states
after my wife and daughter were killed i
went home to see my family never stopped
these stories i love
i love these stories so uh i see people
agree people in the chat are sort of
like acting like i like these stories
maybe one day when i was
when they just had announced that i had
flown
uh 1 million some x number of miles on
air force aircraft
and ange comes up and i'm getting in the
car and he goes joey baby what do you do
and i thought the secret service was
gonna shoot him i said no no no he's
good he's good
true story
and he said i just i don't know what the
hell he's talking about but i love it
big deal whatever was a million two
hundred thousand miles air force you
know how many miles you did amtrak and i
said no angel i don't have any idea pal
he said let me tell you we were at the
retirement dinner
and he said we added it up
you averaged 100 i think it says 21 days
a year
121 days a year 36 years plus as vice
president boom boom you have traveled
over 2 million miles joe i don't hear
any more about the air force
but in the build back better plan i got
more money for pat at least every story
isn't where people are supposedly coming
to him and saying sir sir i don't know
shane
i want to thank you for the introduction
i really do and uh madam mayor page
you've done a great job a great great
job and i really mean it i'm a big fan
and uh i she i when i got elected
i said god's truth after i checked on
what the margin was in the state of
delaware i called up here
she'd won that year too and i found out
that i won every precinct in scranton
and i looked up and said mom
i did it
i did it
look
and it's great to be here
it's great to be here in pennsylvania
with a very close friend become a close
friend and a great governor governor
wolf it's good to see you
and matt thank you for the passport to
let me back into the district
and uh you know uh
uh you know we uh it's interesting i
grew up not very far from bobby where
where excuse me the senator
where he grew up was about uh
a total of if you added it up i think
he's about five blocks six blocks
uh and uh his dad
um and i were about
18 years apart and we're 17 years apart
so it's like a continuum going down here
but i just want you to know we went to
the uh the same schools
same parish
just a few years apart
give her a few take a few years
for all the cringiness of the stories
he just likes people and likes telling
his stories about people he knows and
has known and their background like he
actually knows people as friends which
is very different from trump buying
penny candy
and hanks hoagy's on woodlawn street uh
watching movies of the roosie on the
weekends thanks hoagies trying to
reenact all they did and when you watch
those movies he used to get the meatball
parmesan i was the only kid in my in my
ear that i was able to walk across the
lackey on that pipe that was just above
the thing
if you found the lackey you were you
were lacking you were in trouble but uh
he and i blew up a toilet in the boys
middle school bathroom it was we shut
down the whole thing for three days look
no matter how long
you live here in scranton
it's a place that climbs into your heart
and it never really leaves you and
that's the god's truth
you know it's like that old saying goes
you can take the boy out of scranton but
you can't take scranton out of the boy
there's something special about it
and uh i believe that home is where your
character is etched and i really mean
that
some of you have heard me say this
before
it's where you your view of the world
begins and where you begin and where it
takes shape
and uh that happened to me in 2446 north
washington avenue
we used to come back after 10 30 mass at
st paul's st claire's wasn't built till
i had moved
at st paul's and
my grandfather would hold court and back
in those days all the men had breakfast
in the kitchen my mother was one of five
children four brothers one was lost in
world war ii
and uh a guy who was the chief political
reporter at the newspaper tommy phillips
who was uh lived the street behind us i
was a good friend of my grandfather's
and all the women would go in the dining
room and on the lace tablecloth and have
tea
and the men would
would in fact
have uh have a big breakfast
this story may not actually be going
anywhere or you could sort of wander
around the table you can never sit at
the table
and uh so i used to every once in a
while walk in and just sort of wander
around i'd stand by my grandpop and uh
and uh i uh
um and i put my hand on his shoulder and
i they'd talk and they talked about
everything from sports
and
i would cut this story hey by the way
new feature on twitch it tells me when
someone has never chatted before that's
interesting i want to welcome first time
chat ever from bit w171
uh kind of a cool feature all right very
good
those who know me know it to be true and
you guys know it
is that no one in the world is more
worthy than you joey but everyone's your
equal
everybody's really cool
my mom would remind me she said joey
this is a god's truth remember you're
defined by your courage
and you're redeemed by your loyalty
right you're defined by your courage and
redeemed by your loyalty and my dad
when things got tough in scranton after
the war
when there wasn't any work my dad did
not work in a coal mine my great
grandfather was a mining engineer
but my dad was in sales and he worked
for the fowler trucking company
and things got slow in scranton so we
moved i remember the day he came
i think the longest walk a parent can
make is up a short flight of stairs to
tell their kid you can't live here
anymore
you can't because we dad has dad doesn't
have a job her mom doesn't have a job
and my dad had moved from wilmington
delaware to scranton when he was a
senior in high school a junior in high
school he went then was called saint
thomas not the prep but it's called
saint thomas in those days right and i
remember him walking up and
into the bedroom and saying honey i'm
gonna dad's gonna have to move i'm gonna
but it's gonna probably take about a
year i'll come home every single weekend
it's only 155 miles i thought that was
like
600 miles away i'll come home every
weekend but uh and when when i get
enough we
get enough money i'm gonna bring you and
mom and and everyone down in all
seriousness as much as i love these
stories do you guys think afterwards
anybody comes up to him and says sir
let's cut some of the stories because
they kind of meander
move away
and uh you know i
i i gained so much respect from my
father as i got older because i thought
about how much it
would how much it must have hurt him and
the pride it took it for him to walk
into my grandfather's pantry and say
ambrose is that
can i leave gene and the kids with you i
promise i'll make it up to you but now
i'll be back every weekend but i promise
i'll make it up
that's a hard thing for a proud man or
woman to do
but so many had to do it
and i remember when we moved down to
delaware my dad would say joey and all
my friends know this i'm literally this
phrase you've heard him say it i don't
know how many times
joey your job's about a lot more than a
paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect it's about being able to look
your kid in the eye and say honey it's
gonna be okay think about it
think about what it is
it means a lot more than just whether
you get a paycheck
it defines who you are in his mind
and i learned that at the kitchen table
in scranton a place where you
take care of one another
and uh as i said
my mother i used to stutter badly when i
was a kid if tommy bell and charlie roth
and all of my old friends were here
at saint paul so you know i
my nickname was
blackbird it was blah blah blah bye-bye
blackbird it wasn't men as a compliment
and uh
i wasn't very big but
you could beat me but i'd hurt you
um you think i'm kidding i'm not
and but you know it's one of those
things that uh oh man i was fortunate
because the people i was surrounded by
our neighbors in scranton as well
that people uh
people stuck up for you
stuck up for one another and uh
my mother used to say and i never quite
understood remember joey look at me look
at me joy you're a biden like i'm a
dupont or something you know i mean
europe i swear to god you're a biden
nobody
is better than you
and everybody's equal to you nobody the
point i'm making is the truth is
scranton isn't uh
isn't my home because of the memories it
gave me
it's my home because of the values it
gave me
so when i ran for president i came back
to scranton right i came back to
scranton i started here in scranton and
i resolved to bring scranton values to
bear
to make a fundamental shift in how our
economy works for working people
to build the economy from the ground up
in the middle out not from the top down
i've never known a time in the middle
class has done well the wealthy haven't
done very very well i've never known
such a time
so i'm here today to talk about what's
fundamentally at stake right now for the
families and for our country for most of
the 20th century we led the world by a
significant margin
because we invested in our people we
invested in ourselves
not only in our roads and our highways
and our bridges but on our people and
our families
we didn't just build an interstate
highway system we built a highway to the
sky
to outer space
we were also we invested to win the
space race and we won
we're also among the first to provide
access to free education beginning back
in the late 1800s early 1900s
we invested in our children does anybody
think today if we're making that
decision for the first time
we'd say 12 years is enough
in the 21st century
12 years enough is not but back then
they did and it's a reason why we leapt
ahead of the rest of the world not a
joke
we became among the best educated
countries in the world
but somewhere along the way
we stopped investing in ourselves
america is still the largest economy in
the world we still have the most
productive workers in the world and most
innovative minds but we risk losing our
edge as a nation
you know our infrastructure used to be
the best in the world not a joke the
best in the world today according to the
world economic forum we rank 13th in the
world
in terms of
infrastructure our roads bridges
highways internet the whole works
13th in the world
we used to lead the world in educational
achievement today the organization for
economic cooperation and development in
europe ranks america 35 out of 37 major
companies when it comes to investing in
early childhood education
and talk about an equalizer the greatest
equalizer in the world well a great
university has done studies the last 15
years
you give a kid no matter what the kid's
background from a broken home from a
home where mom or dad didn't go to
school or whatever and you put them in
school third grade you increase by 50
per school not daycare you increase by
56 the chance that they'll complete 12
years of school
and build confidence
what's education all about
it's about building confidence
in a child
it's about giving the tools
to do something
we can't be competitive in the 21st
century economy if we continue to slide
the way we have
that's why i resolve that we have to
once again build america from the bottom
up in the middle out again not the top
down and by the way i'm a capitalist i
think if you can be a millionaire a
billionaire fine
just do your fair share
just do your fair share
you know trickle-down economics has
always failed it hadn't built this
country
you know who built this country
like the young man had just introduced
me
union people people who in fact can make
a decent hard wage
build the country i'm not it's not
hyperbole i mean it from the bottom of
my heart
that's why i propose two critical pieces
of legislation
that are being debated back in
washington
now there's some really smart national
press with me today
and they have understandably believed
that there's no possibility of my
getting this done
this has been declared dead on arrival
from the moment i introduced it well
let's see but i think we're going to
surprise them
because i think people are beginning to
figure out what's at stake
you know when i use the phrase build
back better it's being used
internationally now i got the g7 the
largest countries in the world to agree
that we're going to have a build back
better world and we're going to invest
and we're going to build around the
world the democracies and abilities so
the rest of the countries don't fall
prey to
those like the
the the belt road initiative out of
china and other initiatives where
there's i'll do something for you if you
give me
if you give me
folks look
these bills are not about left versus
right
big thank you to woe geordi for gifting
10 subscriptions on twitch appreciate
that
these bills are about competitiveness
versus complacency
about expanding opportunity
not having opportunity denied
they're about leading the world and
continue to let the world or let it pass
us by and by the way
they will not increase one single penny
of the deficit
they are fully paid for
and all wall street points out they will
grow employment by tens of thousands of
people
tens of thousands of people
17 nobel laureates spontaneously a nobel
laureate economy
in the economy
sent me a letter three weeks ago saying
will also reduce not increase
inflation here's what these initiatives
are all about
first the infrastructure bill when i say
infrastructure back home people look
like infrastructure tell me what tell
you talking about joe they know
infrastructure generically
but it's about rebuilding the arteries
of our economy
that's what it's about
across this country right now
there are forty five thousand bridges
according to society of engineers forty
five thousand
a significant portion they're ready to
fall
fall
fall into the water into the gap that
they cover
there are 173 miles of roads in poor
conditions that have to be built up
including more than 3
hundred bridges and over seven thousand
five hundred miles of highways here in
the state of pennsylvania
that need to be repaired and built
increase
timing and commerce
we're gonna put hard-working americans
on the job to bring our infrastructure
up to speed
good union jobs
not seven dollars an hour or fifteen
dollars an hour but prevailing wage
a wage you can raise your family on you
can look at your family with pride
jobs that can't be outsourced
jobs replacing lead water pipes like you
have here in the scranton area
kids getting brain damage because of the
ingestion of lead
clean water all across america we're
going to replace every single lead pipe
in the nation
again creating jobs but doing more than
that
increasing the health
and well-being of our children
44 000 schools are in a position where
they have lead pipes you send your kid
to the water fountain you got to wonder
about it
jobs laying thousands of miles on
transmission lines
and building a modern energy grid
folks
we're in a situation now where you see
what's happening and i've flown all over
this country since coming in you realize
more
of our land has been burned to the
ground
burned to the ground
in the west and the northwest than the
entire state new jersey
every single square mile in new jersey
more has been burned down this year
this year
in the west because of climate change it
is crazy 2021 united states
there are still lead pipes
there's still asbestos
there's places still that flint that
still don't have just like oh yeah you
can just drink the water
um it's it's wild
we know that we in fact allow people to
be able to store we have this incredible
energy
we have i've visited one of the largest
the largest uh
solar fields in america
it's in the southwest
guess what
you can transmit all that energy enough
to really light up half the half of the
state of nevada
but guess what how do you transmit it
what lines do you put it over do we have
the capacity to do that
we have the engineering capacity but do
we have the will to do it and imagine
what that does
if you realize we had
90 billion dollars and lost this
calendar year
because of natural disasters 90 billion
dollars
jobs
making sure there's a high-speed
internet affordable and available
anywhere everywhere in america including
for nearly one in six families who go
without internet
they're kind of you saw what's happened
when we've had this coveted
try teaching from home how many people
just see out in mcdonald's parking lots
with their kids in their cars because
they get access to the internet
to be able to help the kid in school
what are we doing this is the united
states of america damn it
what are we doing
and both these bills are going to help
us meet the moment on the climate crisis
in a way that creates good jobs
makes us more economically competitive
66 billion dollars in passenger rail and
freight rail
why i always talk about passenger rail
and particularly high-speed rail you
realize the chinese are now building
another high-speed rail line that will
go up to 300 miles per hour
i said does that make biden well guess
what if you can get in the train
and go from here to washington much
faster than you go in an automobile you
take a train right you take the train
we will take literally
millions of automobiles off the road
off the road
saving tens of millions of barrels of
oil
dealing with cleaning up the air
this is not hyperbole this is a fact
these are facts
right now when i went out to silicon
valley they showed we're in a situation
where
if you put solar panels on your roof
guess what when when the sun's not
shining
you're in trouble except they have now
battery technology you can have
batteries in your basement about the
size of the width of this podium right
and about that thick i'm all set up with
the solar panels now but i don't have
the battery i'm just feeding the grid
we have 39 billion dollars to modernize
american transit i remember riding a
trolley
i lived at the end of the line as they
say in green ridge
three blocks the end of the line
beyond the end of line with the dump
but maloney feel was on the right
and the little league baseball field i
played it was down the bottom of the
hill
but the point is
it made to work
most people live in cities
you know the vast majority of people now
working people live in cities
their jobs are out of town no longer in
town
no longer in town
but 65 do not own an automobile
they live in a blacker hispanic
neighborhood or a poor neighborhood guys
i'm selling the power back to the grid
i'm not giving it away
look
more than seven billion dollars to build
out the national network of electric
vehicle charging stations
the way my grandpop got up here my
grandpa biden who died at mercy hospital
of an aneurysm when he was 46 years old
two months before i was born at mercy
hospital
he was with the american oil company he
was up here opening up gas stations
in 19
that
that's how he got here this was 1942
late 42.
well guess what the same thing happens
we build these just so people know
because i see confusion in the chat
um
i i end up i don't pay for electricity
because it doesn't matter that i'm using
it at a different time than this then
it's sunny uh all the time that it's
sunny i'm selling selling i'm dumping
electricity back to the grid and getting
paid for it and then i use electricity
at night but it cancels out and i end up
with a credit it ends up being like um
you know i don't know how much get the
same salary that you paid the mine
worker to dig the well
they've got to be capped we have
thousands of them need to be capped
in addition to that
we have methane leaks that are all over
and you won't understand in pennsylvania
about that
but guess what increases the health of
the community provides good paying jobs
my plan also makes historic investment
in clean energy
including tax credit for people to do
things like winterize their homes
install solar panels develop clean
energy okay people are saying i'm
pretending not to wait it's somewhere
between 40 and 50
negative my my electric expense is
roughly minus 50 a month something like
that
varies varies they're not in fact
generating any energy from the homes
here in scranton other than renewable
energy
not a joke
and by the way one of the things that
president
uh put me in charge of my
i want to be clear here
president obama put me in charge of when
i was vice president
i was able to invest in that legislation
that we put together i put together
we brought down the price of the of
solar and wind
cheaper than
coal and cheaper than oil on a on a btu
basis it's cheaper
right but the noise this time this part
of the country
but we've got to provide other avenues
for people to make the same kind of
living they used to be able to make
look
all told
i just said this project is going to
save literally hundreds of millions of
barrels of oil annually but folks here
in pennsylvania know the costume in
action when it comes to climate change
extreme weather has cost this state
10 billion over the last decade and
nationally as i said extreme weather
conditions cost 99 billion dollars last
year
and i flew over all this territory and
helicopter
and marine one not a joke
see it not a joke that are down 60 80
feet
concerned about the colorado river
whether or not we're going to be able to
keep things moving not a joke
it's real this is serious stuff
and so
you know it's not going to ease up on
its own we have to invest in our
resilience
building roads higher we can when i say
build back better we're the only country
in the world historically
that's gone through a crisis
and has come out at the other end better
than before the crisis hit
that's who we are as americans not a
joke think about it from those of you
who teach history
think about it
we come out better than it was before
because we don't give up
we invest
we trust our instincts
and so that's what i'm talking about
you know we need more
stronger levees
stronger power grids more durable
able to withstand ever increasing
ferocity intensity of extreme weather
any road it used to be you have a
catastrophe
and the road gets washed out you build
it back to what it was before you can't
build it back to the same standard
you've got to build the road back
literally higher not a joke
because the weather has already changed
and if we don't do something before we
reach 1.5 degrees celsius we're in
trouble
look i've been pat we haven't passed a
major infrastructure bill for decades in
this country
last four years you hear every month is
you know infrastructure month
didn't do a single damn thing nothing
i mean nothing
for four years
we can't afford to sit very strongly
while other countries pass us by
we're going to breathe new life into the
economy in our workforce and here's the
deal
these jobs will create that we're going
to create for people who are too often
left out left behind
the vast majority of the jobs in my
infrastructure bill
don't require a four-year degree
98 don't require a four-year degree
right guess what though it's the
ultimate blue collar blue collar middle
class renewal
real serious work
it needs to get done
folks it isn't enough just to invest in
our physical infrastructure
we also have to invest in our people
which we always did
we invested in our people
that's why the second build is the
so-called build back better plan
so-called here's what it does
it takes education
as i said
when america made 12 years of public
education standard a century ago it gave
us the best educated best prepared
workforce in the world and you saw what
happened
think about what happened after world
war one and how america moved because we
were the best educated overall
country in the world
and we led in the 20th century
but as i said earlier we know that 12
years is not enough any longer to
compete in the 21st century study after
study shows that
earlier our children began to learn the
better for themselves their families and
for the nation
you know you all know the statistics and
some of your teachers and your husband
used to talk to me about this
and it was very basic
that if you come from a home where the
mom or dad have books on the shelf and
on a coffee table and read
and you come from a home where mom or
dad can't read or has a sixth grade
education or has a little difficulty
right
the child coming from the middle class
home is going to have heard a million
more words spoken
not different words spoken
spoken
than the child coming from a
middle-class home
and that's because look what do you want
the problem is some kids are hearing
words that don't make any sense
cepha hide
them they're the people who sit at the
dinner table and still talk they're
engaged
so many homes
mothers or fathers don't have the
capacity
or inclusion to do that
but right now what are we doing
we're lagging behind
today only about half of the three and
four year olds in america are enrolled
in early education at all that's crazy
germany france the uk latvia like what
are they doing their number is over 90
of the children
it's not just early education
according to one study we rank 12th
among advanced economies when it comes
to percentage of our young people who've
attained any sort of post-high school
degree i think 12th in the world
the buildback better plan gets us back
on track
we'll make two years of high quality
preschool available to every child in
america every child
and we're gonna make
this idea make investments education
beyond high school that includes
increasing pell grants
which nearly 200 000 students in
pennsylvania from low-income families
rely on to attend college
we're going to increase it by 500 stuff
to so it becomes 1900
the bill
invests in our workforce providing much
needed breeding room for families my dad
used i remember we moved to wilmington
we finally were able after four years
dad could buy a house
and we lived in a
quoted development was a lovely area in
a suburban area but it was a
three-bedroom split-level home
and we had
four kids and my grandpop
someone just got banned for homophobia
about boot edge edge over on twitch
gotten ugly today
and my bed was upping my headboard and i
didn't have a headboard but my bed was
up against the wall that was on my dad's
mom's bed was up against the wall
and i looked back i i it was great for
us having grandpops and relatives there
i don't know how my parents quite did it
but
i remember one night i'm serious it was
in high school
and dad see i could see i could feel my
dad was restless he'd move and i could
hear it in bed
you guys starting to hear louder and
louder either like geese or screaming in
the background said he got bad news
honey his company just said they're no
longer going to pay for health insurance
well guess what
my dad uses everybody's entitled all
we're looking for is just a little
breathing room
just a little bit of extra room
a little breathing room
how can we compete in the world of
millions of american parents especially
moms
can't join the workforce because they
can't afford the trust of child care or
elder care or they have to stay home
i heard my colleagues speaking before i
did here in pennsylvania the average
annual cost of child care for your
toddlers 11 400 dollars
it's higher in other places
so average two-parent family
two young kids spends 22 percent of
their income for child care every year
i was a single dad for five years
i got elected the senate i got a phone
call before i got sworn in when i was
hiring staff saying my wife and daughter
had just been killed
and my two boys were seriously injured
they were hospitalized for a long time
so that's why i've eventually started a
community but i continued to commute
because i could no more afford and i was
making a lot of money then
now granted i was listed for 36 years
the poorest man in congress but
i was making 42 dollars a year
i didn't think my job was to make money
when i was in congress
this is not a joke
i could no more afford child care
than fly but fortunately
i had a hell of a family those valleys i
talked about
my sister and her husband
after
a little bit
they gave up their home i came home one
night and they moved into my home helped
me raise my kids
five years later no man deserves one
great love let alone two
five years later when i met and married
jill
i came home after the wedding they'd
moved out
my brother jimmy my best friend
my mother
they all helped me take care of my kids
but i couldn't have done it
so i understand how in god's name do
people make it
i think
he could certainly benefit from
tightening up these speeches a bit i
like the stories i would condense the
stories and really interweave them with
the more substantive stuff it's an
average of 14
000 per year in child
state sponsored child
toddler care
america invests 500.
times less than our competitors
here's what it does to our economy you
all know it 30 years ago we ranked seven
in seventh in the world
among advanced economies in the share of
women in the workforce
today in america we rank 23rd
and women are becoming not joke
better educated than men
if you look at and i do about five
college commencements a year
four of those five the valedictorian out
of those classes for the last 10 years
has been a woman
and if you read the data now
we're worried about the number of men
attending college
once again our competitors are investing
we're standing still
my buildback
better plan is designed to get us moving
again look it's going to cut the cost of
child care for most pennsylvania
families in half no middle-income family
will pay more than seven percent of
their income on child care under my
proposal seven percent
it's going to help more people get back
to work in the workforce and make ends
meet
it's also going to extend the historic
middle class tax cut for parents
everybody talks about i and by the way i
have a i i i'm going to say something
self-serving but i i got on pretty well
in the senate for all those years a lot
of republican friends as well as
democratic friends for real
kind of like bobby i mean they're
they're friends we used to travel
together a lot
and here's the deal though
you know what i was able to do we passed
the american rescue plan
and the first month of my administration
which allowed us to have
all the funding for covet and when i
started off there were two million
people in america that had gotten a a
vaccine
well guess what we're up to 190 million
that's how we got it paid for it but
here's the deal
[Applause]
what it meant was
what it meant was that
you know
right now there's a whole new attitude
that's out there
how do we not invest so when that act
that we passed we provided for a child
tax credit
and you heard my introducer speak to it
because we're in such dire straits
we were able to put in a position
a tax cut for middle class people that's
what it is
no one has a tax cut we want to cut the
capital gains tax for the wealthy or
anybody
no one has a problem when we deal with
that
we have over 55 corporations in america
the fortune 500 don't pay a single
solitary penny in taxes not one cent
not one cent
they make 40 billion dollars a year
but when you talk about a tax cut for
middle-class people and that's exactly
what it is
by what we did
increasing
or making a refundable tax cut you know
the way it works now if you made enough
money to have owe more than four
thousand dollars in taxes you had two
kids you got to deduct it
and here's the deal
the fact of the matter is
that if you didn't make that kind of
money you didn't get the benefit at all
it wasn't refundable you didn't get the
benefit at all in the tax cut
because if you didn't have more than
four thousand dollars in taxes you
didn't you know
you you still paid
and it wasn't refundable you didn't get
it back
well here's the way we work it
we said all right for temporarily we're
going to do is make sure there's a child
care tax credit
if you had one kid under seven you get 3
600 bucks a year and if you have one
over 7 to 17
you get three thousand a year we're up
to from 2000. many people noticing an
unusually long speech from joe biden
he's now been speaking for
let's look at exactly how long it's been
right about 38 minutes
very long speech for joe biden for
ordinary people
that's what it does i make no apologies
for it
but look folks
there's so many things that we can do to
change the way in which
we work all of this
and i'm realizing i'm going on here but
the fact is there's so much at stake
so much at stake
look
the fact is that most of all what it
does
is you know we have a sandwich
generation
that exists
and many of you are part of that
generation
you have a mom or dad needs some help
when you get older
and you have a child that needs some
help
if you're going to be able to be in the
workforce
and it's hard as hell
hard as hell to make it work
you got to give these folks a little bit
of breathing room the single greatest
champion for eldercare in the united
states america is this guy right here
bobby casey not a joke
not a joke
the way it works right now
if you qualify for medicaid you have to
have a lower income to qualify for
better
medi
medicaid not medicare medicaid
there are 820 000 seniors
people with older people with
disabilities who are on medicaid on a
waiting list to get home care which
they're entitled to
how many families are living this story
their parents get older
they need some help getting around the
house
making the meals for themselves
don't want to put them in nursing homes
only not only because of the cost but
because of a matter of dignity
they do better they live longer if they
can stay in their own home
but you also don't have the time or the
money to take care of them at home
to do it
so you're just looking for an answer
so your parents can keep living
independently and if they hold here a
second one of the things that is
important think about this
in order to get into that nursing home
you got to sell everything you have
you can't have any
private property
you have to empty your bank account
you have to do it all
to move in a nursing home
i'm not saying nursing homes aren't
valuable they are
they're extremely valuable
but that's not where i remember
my uncle was moved in with his wife into
a assisted living center and he wanted
and the folks who who had built the
facility was a lovely facility in
delaware asked if i'd come and speak on
the on the opening of it and we're
walking out and i said mom isn't this
beautiful
she looked at me said she was then 76
years old she said this is for old
people joey
not for me
but think about it nursing home issues
time families this is the most important
issue they're facing
it's personal
it's personal
and bob casey gets it
when bobby fights for something he never
gives up in case you haven't noticed
so here's what we're going to do
we're going to expand services for
seniors
so families can get help with
well-trained well-paid professionals to
help them take care of their parents at
home to cook a meal for them to get them
their groceries when they need to get
groceries to help them get around
to just put in
in railings on their home on my mom live
with me she moved in with me we should
we finally talked to her doing it
and guess what
my sister takes her up you remember this
genie remembers just talking about this
too
she take takes up to get her
prescriptions
drives her back gets out of the house
and she was a it was this little home
off of our home it was she wouldn't move
into the physically moving house even
though we'd done the whole thing over
for her
and she's just standing there
and moves and breaks her
hip she didn't trip or anything
broke her hip
well guess what
just having a railing just having a
place where she could walk from one room
to the other
and help them in their own home with the
dignity they deserve quite frankly
what we found is that this is more
popular than anything else i'm proposing
when you do this individual polling data
this is extremely popular
because you all feel that obligation to
our parents and we want them to live
with dignity
but because american artist people
understand the need
it's a matter of dignity it's a matter
of pride
look
that's what both these initiatives are
all about
and frankly they're about more than
giving working families a break they're
about positioning our country to compete
in the long haul
economists left right and center agree
earlier this year the wall street outfit
moody's projected that the investments
i'm talking about will create for the
next 20 years on average 2 million
additional jobs per year
good paying jobs is transformative
and we can make these transformation
investments and be fiscally responsible
take the infrastructure bill all those
investments road bridges high speed rail
internet the whole deal
they represent less than one half of one
percent of our economic growth each year
less than one half of one percent
and the cost of the buildback better
bill in terms of adding to the deficit
is zero
zero
zero
not a joke because we're going to pay
for it all
in addition to that half of it is a tax
cut
it's not spending money it's a tax cut
for working-class people
it's about time as i said
and i come from the corporate state of
the world
not a joke more corporations are
are in registered in my state than every
other state in the united states
combined
and i represented the state of dupont as
i used to call it for 36 years
i'm not anti-business
but i'm about just begin pay your fair
share
look folks
under this proposal and under this
proposal on these proposals i'm talking
about
i guarantee you
that no one making under four hundred
thousand dollars
a year will see one single penny in tax
go up
not one
in fact the plan cuts taxes from working
people
and by the way if you notice the you
know the way you usually pay for
infrastructure infrastructure is by
gasoline taxes
i wouldn't allow that because that would
tax people making under 400 000. i'm a
man of my word
not one single penny
when you pay if you make more than less
than 400 000
so
but there's no reason
there's no reason why someone making 400
million dollars a year
by the way you know during this all the
crisis we've had with covent
there's a absolute finite number of
billionaires they can count up in the
tax code
you know how much money the billionaires
made last year collectively
they're not bad guys i'm not saying that
they made one
trillion dollars not a joke increase
their in collective income
one trillion dollars
just pay you fair share
you know
if you are a multi-millionaire or a
billionaire you have a lower tax rate
than a family that has a teacher and a
firefighter
as a percent of taxes you pay
lower
as i said 55 our largest corporations
pay zero in income tax 40 billion bucks
this needs to change
working folks understand that that's why
the despite the attacks and
misinformation
about my plans are still overwhelmingly
supported by the american people
they understand that when families have
a little breathing room
america's in a better spot
and they know this is about dignity and
respect about building an economy from
the bottom up in the middle out not from
the top down
as i said name me a time in american
history and the middle class has done
well but wealthy haven't done very well
name me a time
so let me close with this
for too long working people in this
nation the middle class in this country
the backbone of the country
have been dealt out
it's time to deal them back in
i ran for president
[Applause]
i ran for president saying it was time
to rebuild the backbone of the nation
and by that i was very precise
the middle class has been the back bone
of this nation
i couldn't have been any clearer
that's why i wrote both these bills in
the first place
and took them to the people i campaigned
on them the american people spoke
i land they have no doubt about what i
ran on
both these bills were this all what i
talked about but guess what
81 million people voted for me
more people voted at any time in
american history
[Applause]
not to be denied or worse be ignored
because here's what i know
if we make the investments
there's going to be no stopping america
in the remainder of the 21st century
i've long said and i mean this every
world leader i've known and i've now
spoken to over 60 of them
and i've known them many of them before
that
i tell them it's never ever ever been a
good bet to bet against america
no never
never never
which means it's always a good good bet
to bet on america
that's what these initiatives do
they bet in america it's about believing
in the american people about believing
about believing
just look at the history of the journey
of this nation what becomes clear is
this given half a chance
half a chance
the american people have never ever ever
ever ever ever let the country down
just a fighting chance
no guarantees just a chance
and that's what this is all about
and it does not increase the debt
when you talk about the number we
shouldn't even talk about the numbers
because it's all paid for written in the
same piece of legislation
so you pass the spending you're also
passing the tax cuts and you're passing
the taxes are going to be increased
scranton thanks for always treating me
so nicely i really mean it
god bless you all
and may god protect our troops thank you
[Applause]
there he is president joe biden
[Applause]
you know a lot of stories but the
stories very notably were missing
something
sir you're on the cover of time magazine
i don't even know what i'm doing sir
you're doing very well sir you can't ask
sir your wife is up in the air
sir
you can't ask that mr president sir mr
president sure okay anyway so um
tomorrow night tomorrow night
there is a joe biden town hall on cnn
here's my plan you know that we've gone
back and forth with these sometimes we
do run into elements of copyright
problems with those
here's the plan 7 30 p.m eastern time
tomorrow night
we're gonna do a pre-show on youtube
um twitch
as well as facebook
okay 7 30 p.m eastern tomorrow
moments before 8 p.m eastern time
we are gonna pinch off the twitch stream
and facebook and only go on youtube
where we believe we believe we have a
better chance at getting through the
entire stream
um so that's going to be the plan
tomorrow that's going to be the plan
tomorrow
and um
i hope that you will join me
and uh it's gonna be great all right so
thanks to everybody who signed up twitch
subscriptions etc tomorrow we're gonna
try to get to a thousand twitch
subscribers it's gonna be a big big
uphill battle but we're gonna try
um so let's do it okay we'll see
everybody tomorrow